keeping it simple in the kitchen doesn't
mean you can't have amazing food that
not only looks incredible but tastes
fantastic too
my first recipe is so easy it removes
the stress from cooking and it's a
pleasure to make
chili beef lettuce wraps cooking should
never be a chore
the more you cook the more confident you
become that way
you actually start to enjoy it and
that's the key to good cooking
have a bit of fun along the way this is
minced beef and minced pork the pork
needs to sit in there otherwise the
beef's gonna dry out
it's really important to season the
mince before you cook it
pan nice and hot a touch of olive oil
[Music]
mince in breaking up like that really
helps to sort of
separate it so we can fry it off with a
lot of color
with your spoon just go through
and start breaking that up the most
important thing to remember
is mince is made up of cheap cuts
brisket belly
short rib so it needs help and frying
off the mince for color
is so important if this pan wasn't hot
your mince is going to boil it's a
horrible gray color on there
and there's no flavor on your mince
taste a little bit
[Music]
tastes delicious it's seasoned
beautifully see how crispy it's going
take it much further than you ever taken
mince before
nice and crispy smells incredible
i'm draining it it's crucial it keeps
the mints nice and crispy
let me get rid of that excess fat
that's lovely now just wipe out the pan
then wash it
low gas now we're gonna add texture to
the mince
finely chopped chili ginger
garlic and spring onions spring onions
give this sort of
mince a really nice freshness because it
just gives that crunch
nice and thinly now i'm gonna fry off
the chilis the ginger the garlic first
sesame seed oil teaspoon only in
garlic chili ginger in
fry that off nicely the sesame seed oil
just
lifts up the whole flavour brown sugar
that starts to really caramelize the
chili the garlic
and the ginger mince in
now my fish sauce that gives it the
saltiness
you can see now why it's so important to
get that mince really crispy because
nothing's going soggy staying really
crispy
fresh lime that makes the mince fragrant
and then lime juice roll it
and squeeze that in there incredible
i've got the salty i've got the heat
i've got the sweetness now i've got the
acidicness as well and then finally
my spring onions in right at the last
minute so i've got crunch in there as
well
smells amazing literally cook the mince
now with
sort of 30 seconds to go
off and take it out
[Music]
looks incredible smells so inviting
[Music]
to go with the chili beef i'm making a
simple sweet and spicy dipping sauce
so everyone can dress the crispy mince
to their own taste
dipping sauce a little teaspoon the
brown sugar
soy sauce gives it a nice sort of dark
rich color
sesame seed oil a tablespoon and just
top that up with a tablespoon
of olive oil that stops the sesame seed
all becoming
too rich a teaspoon of fish sauce
and then a touch of chili leave the
seeds in again
i want the heat in that sauce
so impressive and amazing show off
centerpiece lime juice in
in the coriander chop it through once
give that little mix up just check the
seasoning
that's lovely nice and rich now the
lettuce
i'm going to use baby gem because it's
really nice and durable and sort of
quite strong
so you just sort of sit these nice
trimmed lettuce leaves around
now the exciting part to serve take your
lettuce up
spoon in your mince and then
a little touch of dressing just a little
drizzle
nice and that's the secret of having
good easy relaxed food is that
you just help yourself food that looks
and tastes a million bucks
doesn't have to be complex this dish is
as fun to cook
as it is to eat
[Music]
spicy tuna fish cakes i love this recipe
why because it turns this humble
ingredient
a can of tuna into something delicious
just open up and drain
the tuna into a sieve just lightly flake
that
don't press it too hard otherwise you'll
dry out the tuna
now these are water chestnuts just slice
them
nice and thin you can buy them anywhere
any supermarket
chestnuts in fresh ginger
get rid of that rough skin on the
outside
by grating the ginger you get to get all
that really nice
sort of juice in
take your spring onions and just slice
on an angle i like the texture of the
water chestnut
with a spring onion or touch of fresh
coriander
lovely next remove the seeds from a
chili to reduce its heat without losing
any flavor
and finely chop chili's
in kaffir lime leaves roll them up
nice and tight run your knife down the
center
once and just chop
and that makes the fish cake nice and
fragrant
touch of salt a touch of pepper
fish sauce just lightly season
the tuna to bind all those wonderful
ingredients
two whole eggs
and give that a nice little whisk
and then add your eggs
get your hands in there and start mixing
get the mixture roll it hand to hand
and the palm pat them down nicely
to cook add a little ground oil to a hot
pan
at the face of a clock i'm going to go
from 12 all the way around
first one in these fish cakes only take
a few minutes to cook
so keeping track of the order they go in
the pan means you know which one to turn
first
[Music]
give the pan a nice gentle little shake
make sure that nothing's sticking to the
bottom
spatula two fingers on top turn them
over
beautiful that crackling noise is
something you always want because
the tunes are already cooked so we just
lightly frying them and get a nice
crisp outside and gently take them out
smell incredible
let them sit there we're gonna make a
really nice delicious simple dipping
sauce
start off a little pinch of sugar fish
sauce
two tablespoons that gives it the
saltiness
one tablespoon of rice wine vinegar
and some fresh lime juice squeeze all
that lime in there
your fresh coriander lots of coriander
and then give that
a little mix and then you have
the most amazing spicy tuna fish cakes
who would have thought
something as delicious as that can come
out of a can a simple supper in minutes
that's so mouth-wateringly easy and
delicious
you're guaranteed to cook it again and
again
green papaya salad this is a great salad
to serve at a party it's delicious and
robust enough
to last the whole evening without
wilting
first off these are a little dried
shrimp
you can buy them anywhere they smell
almost sort of
of the sea bed into the pestilence for
this salad inspired by my travels across
thailand
i'm starting by making a wonderfully
spicy paste
a little salt in there in
just break them up this paste is like a
staple ingredient in thailand
that's what we're looking for almost
it's like a powder
right next just one clove of garlic
slice up the garlic and get that
into the pest and water bird's eye chili
incredibly hot
powerful but wow it does give an amazing
kick to the paste
in to the mix now
a couple of tablespoons of brown caster
sugar
that softens the blow with a chilli and
then just to give that nice sour taste
a little bit of hot water into this
tamarind paste
it's really tart but sweet paste one
tablespoon in
fish sauce now it's got that almost sort
of pickly
smell slightly salty but the flavor is
intense
two tablespoons in bring that together
and give it a really good mix
some lime juice in half another touch of
tartness the paste is nice and thick and
fragrant but it's got the heat the
sourness the tartness
incredible green papaya
stand it up give it a little peel you
can find green papaya and local asian
shops and bigger supermarkets
and as it doesn't work like more
delicate veg it's perfect for robust
salads
like this i grate it
look that's what i want these
thin slithers next a nice
rich sweet banana shalom
[Music]
nice some carrot carrot gives it
another texture
now little that and mix it
[Music]
finish that off with thai basil and
fresh coriander
thai basil is a much more fragrant
basil it's stronger and it's slightly
thicker as well
like papaya and tamarind paste you can
get thai basil in good supermarkets
and independent asian stores but normal
basil works well too
next prepare the crunchy topping pan
on and toast some peanuts
chop the nuts but it gives a really nice
crunch
in they go roll them around the pan
gas off and just stick them out
now for the exciting part i'm going to
dress the salad
nice spoon of dressing in to the papaya
mix that in
and then finally a nice general
sprinkling
roasted nuts and that is one delicious
very fragrant very robust
green papaya salad so easy to make and
guaranteed
not to go limp a perfect party salad and
with such incredible colors textures and
bold exciting flavors
it's sure to grab your guests attention
for me the secret of a great brunch is
fun and casual
fuss-free cooking and everyone helping
themselves
this is the ultimate steak sandwich you
want the rolls royce
of beef it has to be fillet now
season it beautifully i like to open up
the top of the peppermill to increase
the size of the pepper in the steak so
it gives that
bit of heat nice little chunks
you just roll now nicely all the way
around
now slice the garlic in half
pan nice and hot olive oil in
[Music]
hold the steak and just place it into
the pan don't drop it
at the front of the pan we're going to
tilt the pan forward
to cook the back of the steak dual
purpose now
roll it back and sear underneath
next my garlic and roast that garlic
thyme fry that time i want to hear it
we're not looking for a lot of color
because you're going to dry out the fill
it so just
one end turn it back down and steer the
other end in
lift up your time place it on top of the
garlic
there lift up your fillet and sit that
on
top of your garlic butter in
take a spoon tilt the pan gently
lift up and baste
i've got that scented garlic thyme
flavour
the steak is going to cook evenly
because it's sat on a little
a little bed in the oven for 8 to 10
minutes
[Music]
pan on for the relish you think of a
steak sandwich you think of a
sort of nice heated tomato relish
to make the relish finely dice a red
onion three finger rule
one in front two behind
through and chop wow
next roughly chop a chilli keeping the
seeds in for extra heat
start off with the olive oil into a pan
onions chili
[Music]
generous with the olive oil i want a
nice sort of
rich silky relish from there
take your tomatoes you can't just use
red tomatoes but these
yellow and red make the perfect
combination
now put your salt in
and then roast those tomatoes off
take a wooden spoon and just sort of
break them up
once the skins blister the whole tomato
just starts to release all that
really nice sweet texture a little
teaspoon of cherry vinegar
gives that nice acidic balance the
sweetness
of the tomatoes turn down the gas and
just let them sort of
stew perfectly now a steak sandwich
would not be complete
unless it had the most amazing mustard
mayonnaise
simply add three tablespoons of
mayonnaise to three teaspoons of whole
grain mustard
now i've got the reddish almost down to
like a really nice jam
now i want to make that reddish a little
bit more fragrant
some basil slice it through
sprinkle that basil in there
[Music]
beautiful
look at this
she is my crown jewels
time to take it out
smell is incredible
just based one more time
fill it
touch is quite soft in the center so
it's just coming up to mid-rare let it
rest
at the same time you cooked it it'll be
nice and pink
evenly throughout the steak to make my
sandwich
i'm going to char grill some sliced
chipatta bread season it nicely
just a little drizzle of olive oil i
want to get that bread nice and crispy
pan nice and hot bread
in push it down smell is amazing that
char sort of charcoal flavor once you've
got those marks on the bread
it just stops the bread from becoming
soggy and look at this here it
is stunning on
slice it gently
one beautiful slice
wow it's nice and pink
all the way through and the beef is so
soft it's almost like slicing through
butter let the knife do the work
[Music]
little bit of mayonnaise spread that the
back of the spoon
on both sides next
lettuce take that beautiful slice of
beef
and then relish on top of that beef
and just slice the sandwich in half
beautiful now that's what i call a steak
sandwich
trust me serve the sublime sandwich for
brunch and you'll put a smile on
everyone's face
you